[Applause]
foreign
up of CEOs Founders and experts this is
marketing for the now
[Music]
I haven't seen that for a while how are
you doing Gary I'm good yeah I miss
marketing for now hello everybody see
you all in the comments uh excited to uh
be back uh see a bunch of vaynerx people
in the comments Jen lucico actually
mean Sydney Sydney will get our uh we'll
get our calendars situated
um
uh Andrew I'm excited fun episode
everybody Summer's over you know it's 90
degrees
yes it is back to school we've got we
got an exciting episode here we've got a
whole crew of folks that we're going to
be talking about education retail
business all kinds of exciting things so
let's get in gear first up we've got our
friend Amit sevak who's the CEO of ETS
and he's calling in live from a back to
school conference we are so excited to
have him talk he's the largest private
educational assessment organization and
we are thrilled to have you on our show
today Amit
thanks very much Andrea great to see you
again here he is
I mean it's really great to see you
brother
um why don't you you know because these
go very quickly why don't you give a
quick intro to everybody on uh what ETS
does and then I'll uh rattle in some of
my uh questions that sounds great Gary
uh ETS uh is a educational assessment
company uh we work in K-12 higher ed and
Workforce uh we think of ourselves as a
people forward educational organization
we provide data and insights uh through
a whole range of products and services
we've been around for 75 years uh we
work both in the US and internationally
we're one of the largest educational
organizations in the assessment space
so when you um when you uh think about
the concept of back to school
you know how to how to how to how do you
as a human with your background maybe
you'll give a little bit of that and how
does the organization think about that
framework what comes to mind
back to school is that time of year when
you're getting your kids ready for going
back in the fall and certainly for
college as well uh but I'd like to think
about it Gary also as a time where we as
adults can reflect and think a little
bit about our own learning and um we're
at ETS
doubling down on supporting adults
workers employees of companies uh with
educational products and services so
um I think back to school is is is is is
an extremely important thing I also want
to highlight that you know there's a
seasonality you know we're having this
conversation in September when we
traditionally think about this but so
much of what's happening in the world
now is is a shift from that kind of
calendaring of school lifelong learning
is is happening all year long and that
old notion of you've got to go to high
school for X number of years got to go
to college for X number of years you've
got to learn for four years and then go
earn after for 40 years that's that's
disrupting right there's a much more of
a learn earned model where you're
constantly learning you're constantly
earning based on that learning so um so
it is it is quaint in some way to think
about back to school but I think it's it
also is a reminder for us to really be
thinking about all the Innovation that's
happening in education
when you think about Innovation and
education and I think you're right like
lifelong learning like it you know when
I was growing up it was unheard of for a
32 year old human being in America to be
thinking about learning or you know like
you'd hear like one sin of Blue Moon
somebody going to night classes and
almost always
it was based on the insecurity they had
of not having a certain degree right you
know whereas now the progressive
conversation rightfully so is you know
especially with the way the internet
works side hustles like people now
actually believe that they can change
their careers at 36 if they allocate
digital learning or maybe even physical
learning
you know when you think about Innovation
and education and you think about some
of the challenges look I'm a I'm a
pretty public figure that's been fairly
loud over the last decade of like I do
not believe that College in the way it's
constructed is for everyone in every
scenario especially when you take on an
extraordinary amount of debt and your
natural skills or interest will take you
to a place where that those classes and
that degree will not create the outcome
that you're looking for
I think a lot of times people think that
I'm anti-education when I say I don't
believe in college for everyone I'm
actually the reverse I'm so
uncomfortably pro-education I'm just Pro
self-awareness and reality of one
situation not Universal vanilla ideology
one size fits all
where is the educational sector the
industries the governments the
universities the private and public
organizations how advanced are the
conversations on this Nuance is it
gaining momentum with the actual
behavior of the end consumers both
pre-university college and to what you
just talked about post or is there still
uh a lot of red tape and ideology stuck
in the systems your assessment Gary
after covid
the mood changed in K-12 and higher ed I
mean we just realized how challenged
even broken so many of the elements were
and so now the conversations are much
more about the future how do you
incorporate AI into our educational
system how do you upskill teachers and
professors to be able to offer courses
and content that's relevant for the work
world I'm sorry to interrupt you
um how to incorporate AI into
I'm watching this very carefully because
I have children in the system I'm who I
am
this is one man's point of view this is
not even officially ets's I want to talk
to you as the human now because I want
to actually I'm just so you know I think
you know I I have some worn feelings
towards you some genuinely curious
how many
School infrastructures forget about
teachers and principals because these
are these decisions are made above that
what percentage of the orgs do you think
are actually looking at AI as a positive
because I don't have to tell you almost
all of them have banned Chachi
chat gbt and other aspects because
they're in that short term you can cheat
on a test you can write it like
how many in the macro right now your
assessment how many people are pro
figuring out how you know you say it
but I'm curious of how many people are
living it versus what I'm seeing every
day headline by headline by headline of
band the band the band the band where
are we on AI yeah I there are statistics
that are Banning uh unfortunately
um there's also
um a lot of debate but I would say Gary
that the mood is Shifting we're actually
in that moment right now with when chat
GPT uh hit at the end of last year the
educational system went Whoa We have got
to confront this and address this
um Gary we launched uh in partnership
with code.org and uh the Khan Academy
earlier this year a huge initiative
called Teach AI and the initiative is
exactly that is to Foster not just in
the United States but throughout the
world just the the fundamentals of AI so
what 10 or 20 years ago when we were
encouraging kids to learn coding it's
now teaching um them how to learn the
fundamentals it's the literacy it's the
essentials whether you're an elementary
school middle school kid High School
even if you don't want to become a
software engineer just learning the
fundamentals of what this this means so
I I mean I think there's a movement
under wake area I I really do you are
right that there is a Fear Factor
um in the school system in Parts but
there are I think a lot of voices that
are that are speaking the other way and
saying we got to really know and by the
way to the credit of the Fear Factor
there's there's a lot of Fear Factor in
society on it because it is a profound
technology that will challenge us like
deep fake videos is going to be
something that the world is going to
have to figure out the way we figured
out you know atomic bombs and diseases
like it is a big big deal the fact that
we've lived the last hundred plus years
all treating video show as truth and now
we're going to live through an era where
I mean in three years there's gonna be
videos of me all over the Internet
saying things I never said and it's not
going to be based on the eye easy for
someone to know if I said them or not
and forget about me I'm I'm a pimp on
the ass politicians you know bosses
leaders like there's a lot going on out
here so anyway I it's insane how quickly
we run out of time I want to give you a
minute or two to touch on anything that
you were thinking about going into this
uh fun session on marketing for now on
the back to school edition anything you
want to touch on that we didn't get to
Gary I think it ties into what we were
just chatting about and I just want to
build on it that
the future is moving at a very fast rate
so if you think about education as a
sector just as much as it is a
foundational element of society it's an
industry just like retail or other
sectors the currency that's now emerging
in education is skills and so you were
talking about the traditional higher ed
system not working the traditional
higher ed system is largely based on
time you've got to do 120 credits you've
got to work through you know it's based
on time in a seat right or time in
classes the world is shifting from time
to skills as being the fundamental
currency and I think this is super
exciting and the reason I think it ties
into the whole back to school and ties
into the workforce is because the world
of work is changing so fast AI industry
changes new Industries forming energy
all of the opportunities I see in K-12
and higher ed are really the link to
that world of work and so the through
line here is the new currency the New
Foundation of education is increasingly
becoming skills more personalized
education much more Innovation so we at
ETS are really looking to usher in that
from new products and services and
assessments to new research that we're
doing in this space so we're really
excited to be on this show and I love
the fact that you invited an education
organization uh to put the school in
back to school so thanks for inviting
happy to my friend wishing you success
talk soon thank you
thanks Amit
Gary next up we've got Sophie bambuck
our friend the CMO of the North Face and
she's been there for just over a year
and she's come from some pretty stellar
Brands and look at that background she's
come from everlane Nike Converse where
are you
you're right welcome Sophie I know I
wish I was there I'm in Denver I wish I
wish I was there yeah last minute last
minute background change for you guys hi
I love it how are you I'm doing good how
are you good why don't you tell
everybody for the few that don't know uh
what the North Face is and then we'll
get into it oh gosh The North Face we
are at an outdoor industry uh leader we
make uh we're actually known for
performance uh gear but you know we've
been adopted in youth culture so we now
play across performance and what we call
Performance inspired lifestyle
um and yeah we make all the gears that
goes with it from a barrel footwear
equipment go get your tents and your
sleeping bags as well uh we make all of
that so
um yeah we're uh we're having fun
how is how is you know staying on theme
you know first of all I'm a pretty big
fan of the brand and obviously you have
penetrated popular culture and I'm 47 so
I think when North Face started to
really pop you know in pop culture not
just the utilitarian aspect of the brand
in the outdoors I was in that sweet spot
of late Teenage life and going into it
so it's always been a brand that I've
had a lot of love for
um
how does the brand think about back to
school this is the back-to-school
Edition is that like a big watershed
moment for you you strategize about that
there's a ton of marketers and
entrepreneurs here so I'd love to get
your sense of like where does back to
school sit for your business you've also
been in a lot of places in the past so
you can speak broader as a marketer
where does it sit it's the sixth biggest
holiday it's the 13th it's the first for
some some don't care others it's their
whole business 30 of their business how
do y'all think about it yeah I mean I'll
say maybe to put it
um it's probably the only kind of like
what I call a commercial holiday that
actually lives on our brand map right
because
um it is a time where you can you can
it's a double-edged sword you can do it
wrong uh you either you can lose
yourself as a brand because you're
chasing Revenue you're Chase you're
comping year over year
um you can also
um use that time to actually do it right
and actually really focus on products as
a way to elevate your brand back to
school for the North Face is massive I
mean our backpack business alone is I
mean we we make a ton of the year just
through that back to school window I
mean if when you take your kids to
school every single kid has either the
jacket or other or the backpack and you
know being that brand of choice on the
first day of school is essential that's
how we build loyalty that's how you know
kids build their reputation also on that
a little bit
um so it's really really crucial for it
you just said something that I'm
profoundly interested in I believe that
people misunderstand apparel and fashion
completely and don't understand the
higher plane and you just touched on it
so I'm actually going to use this to
really educate the masses from a
different voice than mine
um
fashion brands that the logo right The
North Face I'm very aware of what that
meant the swoosh that used to work for
we all know what that means all the
guccis and the Pradas and all that like
can you expand on the knowledge base of
the biggest brands in the world of how
much they understand that fashion is
built on
a human's expression to the rest of the
world no different than the haircut
style they chose or whether they wear I
mean look at me right now like it's like
the an emerging have brand my own brand
that's like a Pokemon thing I've decided
to wear facial hair instead of clean
like like the level of expression that
fashion actually is I mean otherwise we
would all wear unbranded cloths and call
it a day can you go to that deepest
highest level what this all means yeah
it's an identity Builder right so the
reality is what we the way I look at it
whether you're fashion or you're
actually creating kind of innovative and
benefit driven product you're serving a
need that the consumer might know or not
know that they have and the majority of
the time we're actually serving a need
of identity they want to be able to
um Express outwardly to the world who
they are and what they stand for
sometimes it is hey I'm an early adopter
I know the coolest things I am into
innovate Nation I care about tech or I
care about sustainability or actually to
your use some people choose to not wear
any brand names because that is also
their identity and they might want to
actually identify with a specific
segment or group or or belief right we
have a huge role in making sure that
people can find themselves in our
product so we actually a lot of the work
that I've been doing over the past year
actually is moving away from consumer
segmentation which is useful when we do
targeted content Etc but moving into
mindsets because we're serving mindset
we're serving the reason why right yeah
because if you're an 18 to 21 year old
you know Latino male like cool but like
your essence may be a 40 I mean I've uh
there's a 22 year old kid in my life
right now the only way to sell to him is
a relative like is to
Market to a 58 year old like Middle
America like simple like like he's just
he's 58 years old he's 22. he's he's
58 so he was just a number
really what we care about is the
behavior we care about the why and what
uh you know gets people there and again
like just even to go back to back to
school and what we were saying it's easy
to lose that focus when you go into a
place where to your point every brand
plays it's basically a menu unlimited
menu of option and you just become one
item against you know so many other so
the the work comes in before and after
to make sure people can find themselves
in the brand and choose the brand at
back to school time and then during back
to school time is really for us like
what is it that we want to elevate I
mean this year we actually made the
conscious decision that back to school
for us would be a backpack campaign but
go in depth tell me where the zipper is
fantastic tell me why we built this for
the outdoor versus hey get your gear The
North Face which is kind of like the
traditional approach the why the
utilitarian one it's about the way
last minute or two for all the CEOs and
CMOS what do they miss about back to
school if they are deep in it like they
are Sharpie or or a fashion brand or or
what are they missing if they're not
deep in it it's like actually not a big
on paper obvious place for them to play
what permission or opportunities are
they not seeing yeah I think um back to
school is breeding ground for false
narrative so what happens often is
you're looking at the results of back to
school and you're like hey you know
putting all my eggs in the Performance
Marketing basket or the more commercial
basket works I'm getting the return and
very often what happens is forgetting or
missing out on the elevated expression
of the brand so like you know
traditional funnel model missing out on
your top kind of like funnel Opportunity
by just focusing on The Middle on the on
the bottom I think that's traditional
like you'll see a lot of that so that's
a risk when you're a part of back to
school when you're not a part of back to
school Actually I don't even know what
you're missing I I you're lucky you're
lucky if you're not a part of back to
school it's not my favorite thing how
about that it's not my favorite is it
not your favorite thing from an
operational standpoint because it comes
in the time of year it's tough to get
orgs big orgs a lot of entrepreneurs
here don't realize what you're dealing
with in these big companies it's tough
to get a lot of done in the summer
in corporate life and number two you've
also already got to be planning for the
holidays and it's kind of in
this middle and it's like it's
almost like weirdly annoying and that's
also usually when you're planning your
three-year planning process and all that
stuff so yeah it's really crazy
um but yeah I mean you know for me it's
just yeah it's it's it's a lot to manage
uh and honestly it's not always the most
aspirational stuff that you do uh you
really have a very clear Roi and clear
goals that you're trying to accomplish
and you know I personally I really like
the elevated brand stuff and you know
the big strategic thinking
um and back to school doesn't always
allow you to do that it fits within it
um but hey it's also back to school now
starts talking like may I mean it's
I mean Santa Claus is in like in April
like everyone's just gotten really oh
Halloween stuff like right now and I'm
like why Halloween stuff everywhere
already I'm like geez can we just enjoy
football coming back anyway love you
thanks so we wish you well bye
thank you Sophie Gary I'm super fired up
about this next to guest he's the CMO of
4-H I don't know if you know about 4-H
but uh you know when I was a little kid
in Wisconsin I was Big Time into 4-H
excuse me I went to high school in
Huntington New Jersey
where 4-H was religion I didn't know
what I was walking into in eighth grade
when I moved I came from Edison New
Jersey never heard of 4-H it was more
City Urban culture and then I got to
Hunterdon County New Jersey and 4-H was
religion
amazing they're the largest Youth
Organization they touched six million
kids it's amazing and Ivan has come from
the music and entertainment industry so
he's done a lot in the two years he's
been there and we're super fired up to
talk to you Ivan thank you Andrea
religion I love it we are religion
That's What It Is Well you know I think
when you are you you know you think
about Boy Scouts Girl Scouts for a you
know you know like you think about these
you know uh Little League Baseball you
think about these institutions that have
formed a lot of our lives especially you
know as the world becomes more digital
kids are spending more and more time
indoors there was a funny Tick Tock Ivan
I saw where this one guy says he makes a
he makes like a tries to make a video
making fun of my generation saying wait
a minute you guys used to drink
water from a hose like didn't you know
there were sinks inside and then like
this woman stitched it and she was like
uh we used to not be allowed in the
house like we used to be outside and
this is how we grew up and it made me
laugh last night and makes me think a
little bit about this combo which is
like these iconic institutions that you
know no no kidding when I say religion I
think back to Jason Riker or Katie Hank
I'm thinking about people in my high
school that I got to know because I
moved in eighth grade I got to know them
by junior senior year and they were
still incredibly passionate about giving
back to 4-H because they referred to
that organization as foundational in
their lives yeah that's what I've come
across as I started my role two years or
two and a half years ago and and sharing
with my network I was surprised how many
folks came out of the Woodworks and
shared similar sentiments you know I was
like wow I didn't know it was that
um you know critical to to your
development but you know two and a half
years in and I realized it's one of
America's great Innovations up there
with Coca-Cola and like McDonald's right
I mean our mission is to create
opportunity for all kids just there just
with that mission alone I was like sign
me up let's do this actually you know
you just gave us the mission statement
give people because I do think a lot of
people don't live in parts of the
country or the world who are watching
and listening that are not familiar with
the organization give us give us a one
minute honor sure so 4-H which is
literally four h's that are on a
four-leaf clover
um has been around for 120 years and
it's always been about providing kids
with Hands-On learning personal growth
and life skills so things like public
speaking running a meeting project
management civil discourse having
empathy giving feedback judging others
like through uh you know
um shows and and and uh I'm sorry to
interrupt you do does 4-H believe it is
an incredibly strong compliment to the
K-12 system that is rampant where it's
teaching a lot of the soft skills and
life skills you know one of the
arguments that people like me always
talk about is like man I really wish I
learned a lot of the stuff that actually
happens once you become 22 in school you
feel you feel like that's a strength the
4-H is rounding out the curriculum
absolutely things like public speaking
and a kid at the age of 9 10 years old
doing a speech in front of tens if not
hundreds of people
um and and overcoming that fear and then
becoming a master speaker that you don't
get that in school right so we are
definitely expanding the toolkit and I
love Sophie's your conversation with
Sophie our product is Six Million ready
leaders that's what we're grooming and
we have our eyes on like 10 million
right we think every kid should be in
this program we'd have a much better
world if if we did that
in The Upfront but for everybody who
might have missed it what were your two
jobs prior to this
so I spent a career in entertainment I
was always drawn to music and I thought
I was going to go and you know tour with
Justin Timberlake
um or or like work at a record label I
ended up doing both not with Justin
Timberlake but I did go on tour as a
musician and then my curiosity grew
um to to sort of like see what other
successes out there beyond music in the
marketing space and that led me to of
you know a very lucky opportunity at
Nickelodeon
um where I really cut my teeth and
learning how to build
did you ever uh interact with Pam
Kaufman there she's one of my mentors
love her to peace she's the one she is
as special of a person in the business
world as there is yeah and she has like
endless amounts of energy I've never
seen her like down she's always positive
and anyone who knows her knows she's a
force but and then I was able to uh you
know parlay that into a good amount of
time at Disney
um which led which led me to this
opportunity where we're at today so
Nickelodeon Disney all these big IPS
entertainment all you know I
clearly love you know what was the
biggest besides how many people were
impacted by 4-H what else was surprising
or different just trying to frame this
up for people that to give them courage
to go into new shifts in their career or
try new things what was what was
surprising and what was most enjoyable
well I think I was intentionally looking
to get out of my comfort zone I am
constantly learning I am always the
dumbest person in the room in the best
possible way I'm surrounded by phds who
are experts in and building great young
people right what about reframing that
and I know you're being self-deprecating
clever but what about reframing that
from dumbest to most curious most
curious I like that that's definitely
because I think I think words matter and
I think a lot of people have imposter
syndrome which really means insecurity
but I could tell that's not what you
were saying by the tone and tenor I
think you know it's funny I'm a big
talker but so it's hard for people to
see it but when they start working with
me they realize my core strength is the
Curiosity and the listening I grasp
pretty quickly not in reading
comprehension which is why I have to do
a lot of verbal meetings but I grasp
quickly which is why I then talk to get
more insights but I think the most
curious person in the room is a very
valuable asset to a team yeah and I'm
constantly learning and going around the
country visiting Farms visiting urban
areas Suburban areas because you know
4-H is in every County across the U.S
which was another aha for me uh growing
up in Brooklyn I didn't have that
exposure uh but now I've seen firsthand
the power of the programming and the
byproduct of that program which is these
kids they are well spoken they are
ambitious they're resilient they're
confident and we're talking about back
to school not a lot has changed some
Nuance here and there from when you and
I started high school but kids want to
feel accepted in each of their personal
groups you know as much as changes
it's all the same thing right just like
to the last thing with Sophie kids are
going to wear the kid robot or
or you know whatever segments like
they're going to wear the brand that's
the hottest I had Z cavaricis these kids
have speaking table like people are
going to always try to identify that way
and people are always going to want to
be accepted every kid on Earth this week
that went into a new school
that was going into a new school maybe
just moved or something that nature or
went to the next school system middle
school high school all they want to do
is be accepted find a friend that's it
self-esteem belonging
um and it's an opportunity for Brands to
show up and help these kids Express
themselves through their individuality
right and 4-H plays in that space
through our programming we're confidence
boosters right so hopefully we you know
we we're building these kids that have
more Swagger they're more confident
they're more empathetic they're just
better citizens bro
I agree I agree that like I but you know
like it's just so exciting to help them
be better citizens but also find balance
right
you know like to me right now what I'm
thinking about is the balance of
everything I think what what I like
about 4-H overall is I think it's a
balanced system to the K-12 system
and and I think in general America
especially is pulling in such different
directions politically business World
socially even you know one thing that
bothers me a little bit Ivan even though
I think about it a lot which is like
I don't know when we grew up there was
less like generational Warfare like I
didn't think us gen xers were like
against the Boomers and I wasn't like
you know like I wasn't mad at the
Millennials I was like pump for them
like right now like people are
identifying with their generation yeah
and I think it's because there's just so
much more information it's more
socialized uh we say it we say it in all
of these convenings
they are aware of it they're more
self-aware of who they are of what
generation they are to me the to me the
great goal of society is to get us to be
all part of one brand called team human
and I feel like unfortunately right now
we're all fine trying to self-identify
into the most narrow places which always
leads to
for all you history Buffs out there war
when you identify with one group over
another religion race country uh we've
got a lot of it and I think one the
thing I see from a bunch of 4-H kids is
um being you said it and I think about
like the old
genre of like be good to your neighbor
like that's gone you know like the
reason us kids were able to go out in
the 80s was we had 39 parents not one or
two right like Robbie turnick's mom was
my mom too so if I was acting a fool in
her backyard I mean in the 80s you might
get spanked by some friend's mom
like was different and I think I
think one of the things at its best what
I think 4-H has done well and I came
across a 4-H kid not too long ago which
is why I was excited that was the topic
that we spoke on at a uh on a train
actually I think was going to Baltimore
uh DC from uh uh just making teaching
these kids how to love themselves so
they can love everybody else yeah and
foragers are more inclined to help you
out you will find when you come across a
4-H and a 4-H Alum right it shows up in
the in in the adult version they're more
inclined to help you out and and extend
that Olive Branch yeah I enjoy this
brother wish you well take care
thank you Ivan boy the cat is going wild
thank you Gary team human
love you talk to you later see you later
okay all right let's bring up zubeen
zubeen is our EVP of e-commerce and
we've got a really exciting conversation
coming up with none other than Kate
Spade right zubeen indeed what an
amazing session we've had so far I can't
wait to chat with Amanda
amazing so we're going to welcome up
Amanda Bob and she runs all things
marketing and e-commerce and focuses on
one of our favorite topics which is we
call it brand performance that that
whole notion of how are we balancing out
brand and Performance Marketing and we
know you're living it every day Amanda
so thanks so much for joining us
of course so happy to be here hi
everyone
hey Amanda uh lovely to see you again
Amanda let's get started
um first of all shout out to Z Cava
Richie hadn't heard that in a long time
and it brought me back to high school
cream sweatshirt I can't get that image
out of my head
um but back to school theme for today
I want to talk to you a little bit about
the marketing side of back to school
consumer Behavior what folks can learn
from your experiences this season and
previous Seasons but specifically this
season can you talk to us a little bit
about the shopping Trends you've seen
from consumers they're unique to this
season versus previous Seasons yeah so
one of the things that we're seeing and
I think it
customers really looking for back to
school product as early as late June and
then we launched a lot of back to school
activity in early July which is a bit
earlier for us so we definitely see this
pull forward in addition I think because
of all of the things that are happening
within the macro economy we see the
consumer being much more price sensitive
and in addition to that she really wants
to see that she's getting value for the
money that she spends so what we saw
more so this year relative to Prior
years was a stronger emphasis on
functionality she wanted to make sure
the laptop would fit in the bags does it
have enough Pockets does it have enough
zippers and so on and so forth whereas
we had some other messaging that we felt
like would be really valuable to the
consumer things about recycled materials
more fashion plays we saw those being
less interesting to her relative to the
functional aspects this year and I think
it's more about again she's looking to
make sure she's squeezing out as much
value for her dollar as possible
so a lot of fascinating points there
let's talk about starting the season
early and starting to Market early
um what kind of drove that and what did
you learn as a result of that and how
could you shift and iterate and be more
agile as a result of starting early yeah
so I think a couple things I think one I
think the consumer is really looking for
moments in the calendar of punctuation
right we know that um one of the things
that gives consumers permission to buy
new clothing and accessories is this
idea of new of starting something new so
I think the more that we can get into
that mindset for her earlier the more it
gives her permission to purchase I think
that's one piece of it the other piece
of it is of course starting early gives
you the opportunity to eke out a little
bit more share relative to your
competitors and then lastly it gives you
the opportunity to think about okay
what's working what's not working and
what do we need to shift as we get into
the peak moment of the season and I
think an example of that is again where
we had some messaging around things that
were perhaps more fashion driven or more
driven around messaging about sustain
ability we saw that wasn't resonating as
strongly so we had the opportunity to
make to make a ship there
so I think that's a fascinating point
there one of the things that we talk uh
to a lot of brands that we work with uh
is this notion that social listening and
really leveraging kind of your.com and
access that you have to first party data
really gives you significant lug up on
those organizations that don't so you
can understand what's working shift
accordingly can you talk to us a little
bit about that process that you realize
that the functional messaging was
outweighing or performing better than
the fashion focused messaging and how
you learn that and what you did as a
result of it yeah so
well here at Kate Spade and at
a table around reading and reacting and
so we look at a variety of different
data points some of that is social
listening some of that is the way that
people are searching on e-commerce some
of that is just Pure Performance data in
terms of what people are clicking on and
engaging on
um so we have a pretty good mechanism
set up in place to be able to listen
um and make some make some changes and
earlier on in the season as I said you
know we thought hey we've got some
product that's got recycled materials in
it and we feel really great about this
and this is a message that we think is
great for the environment and the
consumer will really respond to and it's
not that she didn't respond to it but
what we heard her talking about much
more was questions around functionality
will my laptop fit into this um you know
does it have a pocket for my water
bottle and so on and so forth and when
we started to see those pieces of
feedback come in scale from a variety of
different data points again be it social
listening be it what the consumer was
searching for we had that opportunity to
say okay let's switch out some of the
language that we're using let's switch
out some of the assets that we're using
to make sure that we're putting front
and center the product that she's
looking for because we know especially
in a digital environment if she doesn't
see what she's looking for immediately
from you it's quite easy for her to go
and find it from somewhere else
that's fantastic I think it's again such
a great uh approach to marketing and
really the only way to properly Market
in today's society and based on consumer
Behavior to really listen to what's
happening out there and create this
mechanism as you have that gives you the
ability to shift it gives you the
ability to change your messaging and
creative so that you're addressing what
it is that she's actually interested in
speaking of kind of from that's from a
social digital standpoint how do you
infuse what you're hearing from store
associates into that model yeah so
that's actually a really good point
that's is another piece of input that we
have we have a weekly business recap
meeting and we get lots of feedback from
the sales associates within that
conversation and what was happening here
is we were actually seeing a lot of
synergy between what the consumer was
saying online and what they were saying
in stores to our sales associate so this
was an example of where that all really
dovetailed very nicely and one piece of
feedback from one population
corroborated what we were seeing
elsewhere and so we were able again to
make that change in a wholesale way that
enabled the consumer to better find the
product in store as well as online
that's amazing Amanda as you've heard
from our other guests these sessions go
incredibly quickly so one um you've been
I think you've shared significant amount
of insight for our audience and
hopefully the marketers out there
learning quite a bit and it's helping
them adapt to what they're already in
flight from back to school as well as
what they're going to be doing for the
holidays one final question for you from
your unique vantage point the fashion
industry what do you think is the most
significant change or Trend this
reshaping Fashion retail today and why
should our audience take note
so one of the things that's really
interesting right now is that younger
consumers particularly gen Z there's
this idea that in order to blend in you
have to stand out and it's a bit of a
contradiction in terms in that consumers
are looking to express more
individuality to feel like they're
fitting into the group and so it's a
really interesting thing from a fashion
perspective because historically the
industry is used to hey we set a trend
we set a tone we tell the consumers what
to buy and they pick up on it now what
we have to be able to do is find Nuance
within those Trends and ways to speak to
variety varieties of consumers and
subsets to make pieces of collections or
pieces of product feel like it's their
own and that they can Discover it and
reinterpret it as necessary so they can
feel again like the individual who fits
in with the crowd
that's incredible I love that and I
think that it's so incredible to be able
to have again that organization to your
point and the products that you have
that are from a manufacturing standpoint
I'm sure it's not easy but you're giving
individuals the ability to be individual
and yet to your point feel Blended in
which is quite ironic and yet
society today yeah
Amanda this was lovely thank you so much
for joining us of course thank you for
having me have a wonderful afternoon
beautiful thank you
thank you Amanda and thank you zubeen
always a pleasure likewise all right
next up let's bring Zach Nadler CEO of
Vayner speakers
I love
Zach how's it going I'm doing great how
are you doing
oh I'm so fired up for this conversation
I'm going to keep the intro very brief
because I want to save all the time to
sit back and learn we've got Laura
gastner odding who's a best-selling
author and hopefully you can tell us a
little bit more she's much more than
just an author she's a coach she's a
catalyst she's going to tell us how to
think big and I think we could all use
this in our back to school
um Edition this time in our life so
welcome Laura
thank you Laura welcome to marketing for
the now how are you
oh I think you might be on mute
Andrea are we good back behind the
scenes
how's that is that better
I can't hear uh is that better oh there
we go there we go okay now we're cooking
all right sure
we're still figuring out all the
technical stuff I like this um all right
so we're gonna Dive Right In because we
do only have 10 minutes yes
um and so I love this because the timing
is great this is the back to school
edition and you actually just dropped
off your second son to college so I
can't imagine that when you're writing
wonder how that's what you were talking
about so your latest book Wonder hell
tell us a little bit about what that
feeling is yeah so wonder how is that
moment when you've achieved something
and you're like oh my God it's amazing
it's exciting it's humbling it's
wonderful and also there's a possibility
in front of me that I didn't know
existed and isn't that exciting and
intimidating and anxiety provoking an
imposter syndrome rendering it's amazing
it's wonderful but it's also a hell it's
Wonder hell and I think all of us in
this moment in time are feeling this
this is incredible there's so much more
out there can I go for it
wow yeah I mean I think you articulated
that great because I think it's a
feeling we all have and didn't even
realize we were all having it
um so with this episode being about back
to school and there's so many marketers
that are watching watching this was
thinking someone said it earlier but
this is like the second biggest spending
period for consumers and so when these
marketers are dealing with such an
important time and you know even for
students who are starting something new
there's a lot of self-doubt that can
come into play so can you share some
tips for how these folks can kind of
navigate all the self-doubt when there's
so much at stake yes I think back to
school it's almost like New Year's it's
like the real New Year's right I think
Ann Hanley said that the other day it is
a time of reinvention and renewal of
Hope and optimism it's gonna be my year
finally right but it also comes with
this I don't know it's really going to
be a right it's something to realize I'm
a fraud am I going to get kicked out
uncertainty doubt in security I think
everyone wants to feel special but
nobody wants to feel different and I
think if we look back on some of the
times when we were at our best it wasn't
when we were conforming to what
everybody else was doing I think facts
have a hard time arguing with emotion so
if we make a list of the times when
we're at our best
that's a great way to remind ourselves
that those moments when we were
different we actually were pretty damn
special wow and I mean there's so much
there and I think something that you're
kind of touching on is this idea of
redefining success and I know that
you've written a lot about this but how
do you know whether it's the executives
watching this or students we're living
in such results-oriented world but how
do you kind of navigate that when you're
trying to measure your own success yeah
look I think we are all given these
other definitions and success right
definitions of success handed To Us by
our parents our teachers our bosses and
a lot of times we have to stop and say
you know I can't be insatiably hungry
for someone else's goals so what
actually matters to me now when I was an
entrepreneur running an executive Search
firm I realized that I could go hard
after several results I could either
maximize for profit I could maximize for
Freedom flexibility or I can maximize
for impact in the world and that can
definitely at any given time I could
maybe maximize two of the three of them
but I couldn't really go for all three
so I would sort of set seasons I would
set intentions I'd set goals for periods
of time where I would run hard at one or
two of these you know pretty
consistently and what I found was that
the third always came so if you're like
in this place and you're like I've got
everybody else's definitions being
handed to me I would stop and think what
actually matters to me most what are the
things that are the biggest priority
when all the plates are up in the air
and I can only catch a couple of them
which are the ones I'm gonna really want
because if we go hard at those things
that matter to us most not only do the
rest of them come but we're actually
really good at the things that we really
care about
God that makes a lot of sense and I
think you're prioritizing is something
we could all probably do a lot better or
job at
um and so you know this is actually
marketing for the now right so I wanted
I want to kind of go back to some of the
marketers here and I'm curious like with
wonder how what are the real takeaways
that that marketer specifically can can
learn from
so what I found
you know I talked to a hundred different
glass ceiling shatterers Olympic
medalists startup unicorns all in these
moments of life where everything changed
and every single one of them whether
they were literally starting like a
second billion dollar company which is a
great phrase right a second billion
dollar company or there we should all be
so lucky or they're like at the starting
blocks of the Olympics with a gold medal
in their pockets still wondering like am
I gonna it up on this one this time
or if they were marketing a new product
or something they all found themselves
in these moments and what they realized
was that meaning was the thing that
mattered most so when they were talking
to the consumers when they were trying
to decide if they wanted to do the work
in the dark one nobody could see when
they were trying to put together a new
product what they did is they said what
actually matters to the people who are
going to buy from me judge me make a
decision whether or not I'm gonna get to
the next stage and so for example you
know nobody cares if your product is
made up of you know recycled fabric if
it's not going to help you feel
confident being the best you no one
cares how much memory is on the memory
card if you're not going to be the life
of the party so if marketers are
thinking about going after the what 83
billion dollars of spending that's
happening right now the way that they go
after it is not to talk about your
product or your process but to talk
about the problem that you solve so if
you can see your consumer's problem and
they can feel seen in that problem that
all that's left for you to do is to say
I see you I got you and I'm going to
hold that problem in my hand until our
shared problem goes away so it's really
actually a lot easier to say I solved
your problem than to say let me tell you
the 15 different ways our process is
cool and so that's for the marketers
what are the non-marketers I mean I know
you're an executive search for a long
time so do you have any personal
examples you can share yeah I can tell
you that when I went in in executive
Search I would walk into my client's
office my potential clients offices and
I was like let me tell you how geeked
out I am about how cool our process is
and I crushed it I mean I was really
really good except I didn't sell Jack
and the reason I didn't sell anything
was because at the end of the day and
actually tell them myself their problem
and one day I had a friend on a search
committee I thought he's called me up
afterwards to be like Laura you're
awesome you got the work and he called
me he's like Laura sorry you didn't get
it I was like why and he said let me ask
you a question do you find the world's
best talent I was like of course I do
man that's like table sticks he goes
yeah but you never said it every other
search firm walked in and said we find
the world's best talent now let me tell
you how you walked in and you're like
let me tell you how we do our work and
we never knew that you actually realized
that the thing we cared about most that
we need to find the world's best talent
was the thing you actually did so
starting from where your customer is
where your consumer is and saying we
solved your problem I see your problem
it's real I get it I honor it I'm gonna
solve it now let me tell you how they
don't care about the process or the the
product until you tell them you see
their problem
I love that if it feels like you were
kind of battling your own authentic
authenticity like what do I want to be
and kind of what do I want to stand for
and I mean I'm kind of curious because
with this idea of wonder how and and
would you Dove so much into authenticity
like there's a lot of internal struggles
we all have with battling this success
and especially now right whether it's a
marketer going into the back to school
season or even a student going back to
school how do you balance this kind of
genuine yourself right with such
significant ambition yeah can I tell you
a secret
I don't think ambition is a dirty word
everyone's like oh she's so ambitious
like it's like a bad thing okay what
showing up let me ask you this would
having more money more time more
resources more leverage more market
share more name recognition help you
show up better for the people you love
and the causes you hold dear no
you would you I'd like time yeah okay so
having more time right having more of
anything more money more time more
leverage more power more anything that
would help you show up better
better here right yeah
so it's not your worst it's not not your
ambition it's your responsibility right
I don't think it's a dirty word and I
think being able to show up better for
the people you love like crushing it in
your work so that you had more time to
be with your family I know you just
dropped your daughter at school
yesterday being able to do that more
that allows you to be the most genuine
more authentic version of yourself so
why wouldn't you be hella ambitious so
that you could do more of that I think
they go hand in hand I'm all for
ambition I think ambition is the road to
genuine authenticity I love that well
I'm getting the hook here
um so I want to thank you for joining us
here on marketing for the now uh Andrea
thanks for having us
I think we need a full episode on just
this topic about that later I am I am so
into this and just let's go there's so
many notes incredible thanks to you guys
just thank you
all right and last but not least I want
to welcome up Mindy Shire
I just met Mindy last week but I feel
like I've possibly known her my entire
life I don't know one of the most
brilliant people I've ever met she comes
from the fashion industry but she's now
bringing all of that knowledge and all
that passion to people that have
disabilities
um just incredible work and Mindy I'm so
glad that you could join us um we're
just about to hit Fashion Week which is
interesting
um but would love for you maybe to kick
things off and share just a little bit
about your work um and what got you
especially to be the founder of Runway
of Dreams
absolutely well first of all Andrea
thank you so much for having me this is
such an important topic on such an
important platform so as you mentioned
I'm a fashion designer by trade but I'm
also the mom of a now 18 year old son
who has a rare form of muscular
dystrophy and when he was entering
School in kindergarten our biggest worry
was how was he going to be able to go to
the bathroom on his own if he was
wearing anything that had had buttons
and zippers in it and so we solved that
problem by him wearing sweatpants every
day until he was eight years old and
came home and said Mom I want to wear
jeans I want to wear what everybody else
gets to wear and it was a pivotal moment
in my life in my career that I needed my
eight-year-old to remind me of how
powerful clothing is to who you are as a
human as a person so much of what Laura
and Amanda just talked about
um in terms of confidence and identity
Etc so I modified a pair of his jeans
um and when I saw the massive confidence
that came over him from being able to
not only independently dress himself for
the first time but to go into school
with his head held much higher from a
pair of jeans it opened my eyes to the
fact that there are 1.8 billion people
on our planet that have a disability
it's the largest minority in the world
that any single one of us could be a
part of at any point in our life so how
in the world are we not thinking and
making products for a population that is
so large and so important in in uh our
our world so in 2013 I started Runway of
Dreams foundation with the tiny little
goal of changing the fashion industry to
be inclusive of people with disabilities
in 2016 we partnered with Tommy Hilfiger
made fashion history by developing the
first ever mainstream adaptive clothing
line and that really opened the
floodgates to so many other brands even
other Industries knocking on our door
saying how do we get involved how do we
develop adaptive products so in 2019 I
launched gamut management which is the
first of its kind Consulting and talent
management company exclusively in the
Adaptive space
and Mindy I have to tell you when you
share those statistics at the at Wonder
can the conference that we're at at
wonder I about fell off my chair because
I had no idea that there were 1.8
billion people that are suffering from
disabilities but you also shared
something and I don't remember the the
exact number but just in terms of
economically the opportunity for Brands
and for those that can kind of lean in
it's absolutely a huge business
opportunity at the same time absolutely
it's 13 trillion dollars is the
estimated spending power of this
population that to be completely honest
is still white space it it and and
really think about where we are in our
lives and the world how often do we get
white space this is really still
untapped with huge movers
um in the industry that are really
making strides especially in the fashion
industry but there's an opportunity and
as I shared at the conference
it is really almost impossible to find a
company that has a product or service
that cannot be modified to make it
easier for people with disabilities to
utilize
yeah and you know I was really struck by
some of the examples and you showed a
lot of visuals and things but I think
you know I myself have had a number of
different injuries over time where it's
difficult for me to put
buttons and small buttons or you know
hook it hooks and eyes and when you were
sharing that kind of thing I couldn't
help to feel like you're making the
world you know sort of better and easier
for all kinds of people that maybe
suffering may not in fact have a
declared disability and yet um you know
we all have challenges at different
moments in time and that you any one of
us could have a disability in the future
absolutely and and one um you know fact
that I stated that I think is really
important is when the button and the
buttonhole was developed it was
developed in the 13th century and the
fact that we are still utilizing that
technology when we literally can run our
lives through our phones is such an
opportunity for our in so many
businesses to rethink the way that
things have been done so that more
people can utilize
um the product or service a great
example too one you're wearing and those
are eyeglasses they started out as a
medical device now it is a multi-billion
dollar industry that is solidly even a
part of the fashion industry it is it is
considered an accessory that we as
consumers really love to wear the other
is texting texting was developed as an
alternate way to communicate now it's
the most used form of communication so
really rethinking the way that things
are done so that more people can utilize
the product or service is not only
Innovative but it is adaptive in nature
you know the other thing that uh struck
me is just that all of us are trying to
think more about our diversity you know
our de and I
um initiatives and things like that as
as business people and yet many are not
thinking about populations with
disability whether they're physical
disabilities or I sit on the board of
creative spirit that focuses more on
intellectual disabilities but it does
feel like
um you know this is not we aren't
talking about about this population
enough
um can you share any more about that and
maybe you know are there ways that we
can all become more involved definitely
and that's again one of the reasons why
I'm so grateful to be here because
unfortunately disability classically has
been left out of the Dei conversation
um when again it is the only minority
that is a cross-section to every other
minority you will find them in the world
of disability so it's it's really and
and I shared this with the work that we
are doing currently with Victoria's
Secret and not only helping them to uh
modify their products to have adaptive
uh bras and underwear that's launching
in October and on our runways next week
um but they also
um simultaneously were working
internally and and really in their Dei
statements their HR their sales team how
they are approaching hiring people with
disabilities it is something that
absolutely has to be considered
internally as much as externally
um and that is something that that we
again and take really seriously and and
really helping Brands navigate the
process to become more disability
confident
that's extraordinary so you kind of
hinted at what's going on next next week
we know that um you know New York is uh
is all in on the on the fashion runway
all the shows that are going on can you
tell us a little bit more about what
you're up to absolutely so third this
coming Wednesday the 13th uh we will be
hosting our biggest New York Fashion
Week show where we will have over 70
models with all different disabilities
wearing product from Tommy Hilfiger
Target Kohl's JCPenney Zappos Steve
Madden stride right and actually for the
first time ever product will be debuted
uh from Victoria's Secret uh their first
adaptive products on women of all
different ages ethnicities and and
abilities so it's really going to be a
pivotal moment and I'm so excited that
you're going to be there to experience
it
I can't tell you how excited I am and
we'll make sure that we'll share all
that we can uh with the broader world
it's going to be such a special event
and you know would we'd love for folks
to be leaning in and helping in any way
shape or form if there's anything else
that you could share in terms of a call
to action
um you know feel free to do it but we're
going to be chatting this up on social
uh and hope to have everyone that wants
to join in on this on this Mission
um be a part of it absolutely I mean the
the call to action that I always say is
to talk about it go back to your
companies if you if you no matter what
product or service that you are working
on or if you don't necessarily have one
but internally we could be doing better
think about the numbers that we talked
about 1.8 billion people identify with
having disabilities so that's actually a
much higher number
13 trillion dollars is up for the grabs
for the amount of spending power that
this population has and it's the largest
minority on our planet that every single
one of us could be a part of that is
power we can all do better and make this
world a much more accessible place
we can we can together well thank you so
much Mindy I love you love yourself
and thanks so much for joining us thank
you
all right thanks everyone for joining
this episode this back to school episode
we hope you have a great kickoff
um of the fall and we look forward to
seeing you in our next episode on
October 19th from 12 to 1 p.m Eastern we
will see you then